[Music]
on this Wednesday night a new blood test
for Kovac 19 approved in Canada the
answers it can and cannot provide the
mere presence of antibodies alone does
not mean we are protected plus the frank
assessment of what the world is facing
this virus may never go away
Europe's goal to save summer vacations
safely people need of course to be able
to travel between European countries new
learning curve Canada's post-secondary
schools gear up for a different fall
semester and you've got to be kidding go
go the goats who hope the grass might be
greener on the other side
verbal national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
as we long for an end to the
stranglehold this virus has on the world
there's a sobering reality check tonight
on how much we still don't know about
Koba 19 the World Health Organization
says it's possible it could be years
before it's under control and we may
have to learn to live with it more on
that in just a moment the best case
scenario is a safe effective vaccine
that's made available to everyone that
doesn't exist yet but Health Canada did
announce other progress today it is
approved the first seria logical test in
Canada a test for antibodies to
determine who has been exposed to kovat
19 and who could possibly be immune this
is a critical step for the work of the
kovat 19 immunity task force these tests
will help us better understand immunity
against the virus and how it spreads so
we can keep Canadians safe and healthy
this is not the swab test to find out if
you have an active case of copán 19 it's
a blood test to detect antibodies which
would reveal if you've been infected in
the past perhaps without any symptoms
here's why that's important there are
now more than 72,000 confirmed cases of
copán 19 in Canada those account for the
people tested it doesn't account for
those who have the virus but showed few
or no symptoms and were never tested so
we still don't know how prevalent the
virus is in society nor do we know how
many people might be immune to it
without that it's difficult to know
where restrictions can be safely lifted
there's still a great deal we don't know
Heather York's West explains how this
newly approved test works and the
questions it might help answer the
company behind the first kovat 19
serology tests approved for use in
Canada is from one of the first
countries to be hit hard by kovat 19
defective italy unfortunately have over
30,000 and dead people from this really
devastating pandemic gave us the
opportunity to very quickly and have
clinical samples and develop a very good
assay the blood test was approved for
use in Europe in the u.s. at the end of
April the company says it's now shipping
kits worldwide it
to produce five million this month ten
million in June I can tell you that ten
million per month which sounds like a
huge number it's a fraction of what
countries are looking for having an
effective serological tests is vital
especially as businesses start to look
at reopening because knowing who has
already had this virus could help public
health officials determine who may be
immune to future infections problem is
we still don't know enough about this
virus to be sure the mere presence of
antibodies along does not mean we are
protected and we shouldn't be using this
as a green light to say that we are
fully immune to the virus we have to
study the immunology the immune response
to the virus at the same time and then
we can interpret these tests as to what
they mean for an individual for now dr.
Teresa Tam sees the new test as a
research tool a way to learn more about
how the virus behaves it will also be
used to determine how many Canadians may
have been infected during this first
wave the approach that we're taking in
Canada is to use these tests first of
all in the context of population studies
this is a fantastic tool this is going
to provide a lot of insight but this is
not at this point a gateway to know
who's fully protected and safe to go
back to work with no other precautions
so while something like an immunity
passport may not be here yet it is
getting closer and the approval of this
test is an important step Heather your
ex West Global News Calgary now two the
hard reality check from the World Health
Organization today dr. Mike Ryan an
epidemiologist and head of the
Emergencies program says Kovac 19 may be
with us for years there is still so much
we don't understand about the virus and
he says no one can make promises or give
firm dates on when it will no longer be
public enemy number one
I think it's important too to put this
on the table this virus may become just
another endemic virus in our communities
and this virus may never go away HIV has
not gone away we've come to terms with
the virus and we have found the
therapies and we found the prevention
methods and I'm not comparing the two
diseases but I think it is important
that we're
realistic and I don't think anyone can
predict when or if this disease will
disappear we do a one great hope if we
do find a highly effective vaccine that
we can distribute to to everyone who
needs it in the world
one of the many uncertainties about the
virus is the impact on children few kids
are getting sick but some are getting
very sick with a mysterious syndrome
believed to be linked to kovat 19
Ontario's Health Ministry has revised
its definition of kovat 19 now to
include what's referred to as a
multi-system inflammatory vasculitis a
condition similar to Kawasaki syndrome a
direct connection between the corona
virus and this syndrome has not been
confirmed doctors and patients are urged
to monitor kids for symptoms including
persistent fever rash abdominal pain
vomiting and diarrhea there have been
reports of deaths and children
associated with inflammatory illnesses
in other countries none here in Canada a
nurse who worked at a long-term care
home in Ontario has become that
provinces first registered nurse to die
of kovat 19 Brian D D worked at
Kensington village in London Ontario had
been off work getting treatment when he
died seven other staff members at the
home of also tested positive BD is being
remembered as a dedicated employee who
loved his job and considered his
colleagues and the residents of the home
his other family five residents at the
home have died of kovat 19 and there are
still three active cases the Ontario
government now has the power to step in
if a long-term care home is struggling
to cope with an outbreak the province
has issued a new emergency order that
would allow it to replace the management
of facilities that have a high number of
infections or deaths or if there's a
staffing shortage it's just a tool in
our toolbox to use if we need it so that
we can move in rapidly if there's some
care homes that continue to have
problems and are resistant to having any
assistance then we know that we will be
able to get in there quickly because we
want to save lives Ontario is also
redeploying education support workers
who aren't engaged in distance learning
right now to help out in care homes and
hospitals there are a hundred and eighty
outbreaks at long-term care homes and on
cheerio and more than 43-hundred
confirmed cases Ontario's premier made
it clear again today he doesn't think
the time is right to reopen the border
between Canada and the US Doug Ford says
it's just too risky he and the premiers
of Quebec and DC told the Prime Minister
this week they don't want travel
restrictions eased when the canada-us
border deal expires May 21st
negotiations are under way to extend
that restriction the border has been
closed to all non-essential travel since
March 21st and Canada is trying to keep
it that way until at least June 21st
conversations are ongoing our
constructive or productive I won't make
any announcements today but I can say
that things are going well and we're
confident about being able to continue
to keep Canadians safe
Europe is also looking at loosening
border restrictions in hopes of
salvaging part of summer tourist season
a little later we'll look at what's
being planned and is a European vacation
realistic in the race for a vaccine one
company says the US will get a leg up
the head of French pharmaceutical giant
Sanofi says the US will likely be the
first to get the vaccine if that company
successfully develops one the CEO told
Bloomberg News that's because the US
government was first in line to fund
Sanofi vaccine research it partnered
with UK company GlaxoSmithKline and
hopes to start human clinical trials
this fall it's one of about 100 vaccine
candidates in the preclinical phase
eight others have begun human clinical
trials if one of them works as a pushed
by some countries for equitable access
for all but it's unlikely every country
will get it at the same time in the US
there's a battle between the politicians
and the scientists over how to tackle
cope in 19 our Washington bureau chief
Jackson prosecco joins us late today
Jackson president Trump spoke to
reporters and he contradicted the
country's top doctor What did he say hi
Donna this battle between science and
politics really has become a feature of
the White House response some Trump
administration officials are now
reportedly casting doubts on the
official death toll numbers provided by
the CDC believe
they're too high and you're right a
short time ago the president disparaged
his own top infectious disease expert
dr. Anthony foutch II yesterday fowey
testified that it may be unwise to send
children back to the school in the fall
without a vaccine because there's so
much about this disease and its impact
on young people that remains unknown but
the president is firing back
he himself of course is not a doctor he
believes this disease Oh only impacts
older people and a short time ago he
lambaste it about his testimony because
you know it's just to me it's not an
acceptable answer
Jackson without a vaccine which we don't
have testing is one part of the way to
contain outbreaks of koban 19 at least
two staff members at the White House had
tested positive now the vice president
and the president are both being tested
every day but there's concern about the
reliability of those tests
that's right specifically the
reliability of a 15-minute rapid test
that's really been promoted by the White
House and used by the White House on the
people closest to the president and vice
president a new study from NYU finds
that it's missing between 30 and 50
percent of positive cases that's a huge
problem especially considering the
circumstances it's being used under we
should point out this study as
preliminary has not been peer reviewed
and essentially calls into question the
need for more research Donna like so
much to do with this virus there are a
lot of unknowns and a lot of concerns
that the fuller picture of the virus and
it's spread is still being missed all
right Jackson cross go in Washington
thanks the FBI says it is investigating
hackers affiliated with China who are
targeting researchers working on kovat
19 treatments it says health care
pharmaceutical and research
organizations are considered prime
targets and says they should take all
necessary action to protect their
systems from being compromised the FBI
recommends monitoring for unauthorized
access and warns the media attention
linking an organization with kovat 19
related research will lead to increased
interest in cyber activity president
Trump's former campaign manager Paul
Madoff
has been released early from prison
because of the risk of kovat 19 in jail
Matta Fort will serve the remainder of
his seven and a half year sentence from
home the 71 year old was convicted on a
number of crimes including tax fraud and
foreign lobbying violations mana for it
is one of more than 2500 federal
prisoners in the u.s. who have been
released because of the pandemic and
will serve their time under home
confinement Canadian Big Oil blacklisted
coming up why it's being shut out of the
world's largest wealth fund
with the approach of summer many people
are wondering what their holidays will
look like the tourism industry
everywhere has been hit hard today the
European Commission set out some
guidelines for how businesses in Europe
might try to salvage the summer travel
season crystal commencing reports a
sun-drenched Beach vacation sounds
fabulous but getaways seem far off in a
world where garden centers are just
opening this is our bread and butter
Tomi yeah this is when we get excited
this is also bread and butter time for
the tourism sector it's unlikely
Canadians will be taking in the sights
from the London Eye or any other popular
spot instead the idea is to target the
roughly 400 million people within Europe
hotels restaurants beaches other tourist
sites they need to be run in a way that
minimizes the risk of passing on the
coronavirus European Union member states
are encouraged to reestablish free
movement and guidance is being offered
to the tourism sector resorts for
example are instructed to start
preparing locations where groups would
gather so they can be physically
distanced to allow for digital bookings
of pool areas and dining locations and
to get workers protective equipment the
recommendations come weeks after Greece
for example said a wanted to open to
Europeans everyone is waiting to see if
the 2020 season can be salvaged this is
a million-dollar question of course this
depends on all the countries and how
they fare with this crisis but we're
aiming to open up sometime in July many
cities hit hardest by the virus rely on
tourism and have been struggling
financially
even before the pandemic and now most
travel will be across land borders
rather than flying into locations
farther from home you're asking people
to counter fear and fears and risks a
much more manageable the closer to home
there
the industry hopes it'll be a short
transition from picking up crimson
flowers to taking in a golden sky
crystal commencing Global News London
there's some confusion in the UK over
government plans to ease lockdown
measures there after seven weeks people
are being allowed more freedom to get
outside and they've been encouraged to
go to work if they can't work from home
but also told to avoid public
transportation that's not easy in a city
like London the government also advises
to wear face coverings on transit but
that's not mandatory a plan outlined on
Monday is a phased in approach to ending
the lockdown restrictions critics say
it's confusing and potentially dangerous
there's another major blow to Canada's
struggling oil and gas sector Norway's
sovereign wealth fund the world's
largest announced today it will stop
investing in four Canadian companies
Norwich Bank says it will no longer
invest in Imperial Oil Sun courts in
crude and Canadian natural resources
because they produce what it calls
unacceptable levels of greenhouse gas
emissions it's the first time emissions
have been stated as the reason for
excluding companies on ethical grounds
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau says the
news is part of a continuing shift in
global attitudes and oil companies will
have to adjust many companies in the
energy sector have understood that the
investment climate is shifting and there
is a need for clear leadership and clear
targets to reach on fighting climate
change to draw on global capital since
the year 2000 the companies operating in
Canada's oil sands have reduced their
per barrel emissions by 28 percent but
production has increased and overall
greenhouse gas emissions have continued
to rise Canada is one of the biggest
emitters per capita of greenhouse gases
the Obama's video bomb a virtual Town
Hall gets some surprise guests
you are watching global national
[Music]
Brazil is now the epicenter of the copa
de 19 crisis in latin america and it has
recorded its deadliest day 881 people
are known to have died from the virus in
Brazil on Tuesday bringing the country's
total death toll to over 12,000 Brazil
is now the sixth worst affected country
in the world but it is only testing
people who end up in the hospital and
experts say the scale of the outbreak
there is likely much worse state and
city governments are proceeding with
mandatory lockdowns against the will of
brazil's president who has said that job
losses are more damaging than the virus
Southern Africa's tiny mountain kingdom
of Lesotho has confirmed its first case
of kovat 19 it is the last of Africa's
54 countries to report the disease the
nation of two million is surrounded by
South Africa which has the highest
number of confirmed cases on the
continent with limited testing in many
African countries there are concerns the
number of Coe bid 19 cases could
actually be much higher post-secondary
education in the pandemic next what
classes could look like this fall
when we heard that there was going to be
a civic town-hall going on Michelle and
I decided we were going to crash as
former US President Barack Obama and his
wife zooming into a high school civics
class they surprised these students in
Chicago encouraging them to stay engaged
in reminding them the power they have
and the role they play in the future of
the country and in democracy it is an
uncertain time for a Canadian University
students to Kovach 19 has forced many
post-secondary schools to change the way
they will be offering classes in the
fall some universities have already
decided they'll move entirely online
offering no campus experience at all
as Michael Couture explains that's
prompting some students to reconsider
their plans for September these days
Charles Wolfe spends more time doing
yard work than school work the second
year McGill student is back home in
Ottawa and isn't sure he wants to do his
online semester from here I can't really
focus at home I went to boarding school
before so coming home is kind of like
it's always a holiday so I don't do work
here so it's so hard to do work here and
it's not like I can go to that you Auto
library and do work there because that's
also closed Yale is one of several
post-secondary institutions moving most
fall courses to remote platforms the
University of British Columbia is moving
larger classes into virtual classrooms
with a select number being offered in
person but still respecting physical
distancing the Western University is
also leaning towards a mixed model
president Alan Shepard admits striking
the right balance hasn't been easy
there's no pandemic playbook for
universities it's very complicated it's
huge no it's it's hundreds and probably
thousands of logistical decisions very
very complicated and students feel the
struggle too I can't go in and talk to a
person asking questions personally it's
all over video and you know you can't
show your laptop to a professor on video
if the laptop is the video now imagine
if you're in medicine or another
hands-on program replacing that
practical experience is practically
impossible a cost is another
consideration with many students saying
tuition hasn't decreased according to a
recent survey for the Canadian
Association of Universe
city teachers and the Canadian
Federation of students 30% of returning
and new students might change their
plans about enrolling at a
post-secondary institution this fall
that includes Amina Shaquille who is
supposed to start University in a few
months I had it all planned out like the
school I wanted to go to the program the
residents I was applying for and then
when I found out that most schools were
going to be online I kind of just threw
off plan and with so much uncertainty so
many students are unsure of where
they'll be in just three months my clue
kut'r global news Ottawa and that is
global national for this Wednesday I'm
donor Friesen you know that saying the
grass is always greener
police goats tried to prove it they
broke through their fence and made a run
for it through a San Jose California
neighborhood they weren't kidding around
some stopped for a snack on some local
delicacies before they were wrangled
back their pen thanks for watching take
care of yourselves
bye bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]